did you have fun at the voice i had a
great time at the voice did you
enjoy i did but i've been mega mentor
though before and you're there
so much longer because you had to do all
the teams
you don't remind me yeah definitely it's
a long time
yeah it's good though so we we just saw
each other there though and um
i heard and i didn't know this the day
of but i just found this out did you
have your own trailer
i did i was like i love it it wasn't you
i figured you know with
covet rules it'd be better to just kind
of bring your own you know what i'm
saying i love you normally you like
bring your own lunch i like brought my
own
it is like idea of a trailer so cousin
eddie from it's so casualty i'm
so down with it um so
do you do you bring your trailer
everywhere or is it just we were special
as a
as of a recent yeah i mean i think i
made it uh a home away from home
everywhere i go i've been able to kind
of drive that thing
uh up north in california and go to
yosemite park
and uh you know just just enjoy this
moment make the most of these moments
yeah
a lot of people have seen a bit more of
national parks than they
generally would take time for because of
that kind of stuff and they're beautiful
everybody's super comfortable though by
the way yeah it is
it's hot yeah but it's definitely it's
hot i'm out
[Music]